so
i've been given the
distressing task of talking to you about
fat tales and climate change and climate
economics in particular
focusing on climate sensitivity so i'll
say something about these things and so
the focus of the workshop is kind of
sensitivity a lot of the talk will be
about that and some of the things you'll
have seen before this is the cost of
going after lunch and talking about
science when you're not a scientist
um
but uh
uh
you can hear me
no
better yes okay um
but i also oh wow okay i'll also talk a
little bit about um
sort of some reflections on on the
process of economic modeling and what we
should maybe be doing with our economic
models to make them
useful for policy making this is really
really what i'm interested in is making
good decisions in the real world
um and i think models are an
indescent indispensable part of that uh
task but they are contentious
um so i sort of start provocatively with
uh with a couple of quotes one
advocating the benefits of abstraction
by a non-economist
and the other excoriating economists for
purely being abstract by an economist
okay
who's not a model
which is i mean that may or may not be a
sort of
a thing in his favor i don't know
um so uh so the primo levy says you know
we're compelled to reduce the noble to a
schema that's that's really what
modeling is right we can't make
decisions in the world if we say well
everything's just so bloody complex we
can't see you know our way through the
through the cloud and balding
was was sort of fundamentally skeptical
of of the role of of mathematics and
abstraction and economics sort of um you
know
mathematics brought rigor to economics
but unfortunately also brought mortis
and uh
i think that i mean that's certainly
going too far but um
there is something in this idea that
once you've finished modeling something
you're done right
um so
i think that that may well be true from
the perspective of
seeing modeling as a purely intellectual
exercise but when you take a model into
the real world and people's livelihoods
are suddenly on the line based on the
decisions that you inform
with that model there's a new
kind of set of issues that that become
relevant to
assessing what we mean by model quality
and and the usefulness of the model
um so i'm going to make five very simple
points
uh one point some of them have been made
before so i'll do them sort of quite
quickly one is that we don't know the
right distribution of climate
sensitivity and argue that that's okay
you know don't worry about it
um the other is we're unlikely to learn
about the distribution of climate
sensitivity
or at least we're unlikely to learn
about it much faster than we observe
things right
the third is that
fat tails and catastrophes pose
problems for integrated assessment
models but they're not a priori
insurmountable
the fourth point is that climate
sensitivity is probably not the most
important uncertainty in integrated
assessment models
and
we must be aware of the street light
effect and i'll explain what that is in
a minute and the fifth point is that
we should do everything we can to
quantify the structural uncertainties in
integrated assessment models empirically
so basically what i'm interested in is
how wrong could we go by using these
models and the structural relationships
that are in these long lists okay
so what does an integrated assessment
model look like what looks something
like this
so usually what you do is you have a
bunch of scientific inputs you have some
sites uh climate model forced by
emissions from economic output and that
those uh that uh those emissions drive
temperature changes which drive uh um
impacts on the economy which we value in
some way
there are assumptions about how
technologies change how um the decisions
that we make about savings and
mitigation trans uh translate into
economic productivity and into emissions
and there are assumptions about how
those emissions and changes in
temperature
translate into economic damages then we
we sort of take the soup
give it a good stir and we evaluate it
using meth very very well established
methods in economics there's some
something called an evaluation framework
which is basically a way of aggregating
benefits and costs that are distributed
over states of the world and time um
and people if you have a regional model
and we make our policy recommendations
i'm going to argue that you know each of
these links in the chain is uncertain
um but the uncertainties are not the
same there are uncertainties that come
from different components
and we need to understand and probe
those uncertainties as much as we can in
order to make the models relevant for
policy
so this you've seen before um so climate
sensitivity in fact this is i think the
third time you're seeing this today so
um
so uh climate sensitivity distributions
what does the science tell us well
here's a bunch of models that are taken
from the scientific literature collated
by 9000. um
what what do economic models usually
assume they usually assume it's
something like that so what i've done
there just taken an equally weighted
average of all of those those
distributions
um and in fact a lot of the models would
just assume that there's a delta
function right that there's a single
known value of climate sensitivity and
then do sensitivity analysis over that
value
um
and
so the point so jeff's talked a lot
already about the sort of difficulties
of going from here to here and bill's
already talked about the desirability of
going to from here to here and i have
sympathy with both points of view right
i would love to be in a world like this
but i also recognize that we're probably
in a world like this and we're unlikely
to go from here to here without
introducing quite a lot of subjectivity
into
the analysis that we're doing right now
maybe you're comfortable with that but i
think that that subjectivity is
something that policymakers need to know
about they need to know that you're
putting some assumptions onto the data
or onto the models that are in some
sense independent of their empirical
structure right so whether you do that
by running an integrated assessment
model with each of these distributions
and outputting 20 values for the social
cost of carbon or you sort of aggregate
them in some way and you make those
subjective weighted judgments but have a
modeling framework that allows you to
maintain a distinction between
subjective and objective is it's about
it's a sort of methodological choice
um and i think both of them have
applicability um
so uh
learning about climate sensitivity so i
think gary talked about the value of
information uh i think he wasn't really
talking about climate sensitivity he was
talking about a sort of adaptation
decision but i think there's been quite
a lot of work in fact i think um bill's
done some of the work on um uh the value
of information about climate sensitivity
and certainly charlie colstadt and um
david kelly in miami uh have worked on
this and uh you know
this idea that well you know the value
of information about climate sensitivity
is clearly very high we would be much
better off if we knew its value than uh
than having to make this decision under
sort of
a lot of risk um unfortunately
history suggests that uh that that value
is not realizable right it suggests that
um
the only way that we're going to learn
about clients climate sensitivity is by
observing stuff
and those observations are going to
become come realized in real real time
right we're not going to have some
technological or scientific silver
bullets that really narrows this
distribution of climate sensitivity and
i'll argue that even if we did it would
still
there would still be a role
to play for the tales of this
distribution so here you're looking at
the estimates over time so here's one
going back to the 1880s and this is by
the way stolen from steve schwartz's
website
and uh the distributions certainly in in
the last 20 or 30 years really haven't
changed all that much we've maybe become
more confident about those distributions
um and maybe we understand where they
come from and how the data constrain the
distributions more um but in terms of
like looking at the
the range of possible values it hasn't
changed a whole lot um so that seems to
have quite a lot of consequences for how
you would want to make policy right so
you can assume that um
you know there's a in fact there are
arguments in economics that suggest well
you know irreversibility and learning
are coupled things that uh have a strong
effect on the policy choices you want to
make so if you can afford to delay an
irreversible decision like installing
some some
renewable energy capital for example
and wait for more information to learn
about the benefits of that installation
you should
but that is conditional on that
information becoming available on policy
relevant time scales and arguably you
know we have sort of 40 50 years to
really kill this climate problem
or make make serious inroads into it and
uh arguably on those time scales climate
sensitivity is not going to change very
very much
so i would argue that really the policy
decisions we're going to make are
basically going to have to be based on
the kind of information that we have at
the moment
if it's not going to change
the the knowledge of it yeah sorry good
clarification um
so um
you've seen the steve showed you a
picture a little bit like this before so
here i mean the crucial thing with
climate sensitivity is that climate
sensitivity is inversely related to the
things that you observe right so when
you have uncertainty in the things that
you observe that translates into a
skewed distribution for the thing you
care about
and it's skewed and more of a fat tailed
and so this sort of the the top of this
distribution of observable of
uncertainty and feedback really drives
um the uncertainty in climate
sensitivity so here um if you look at
the difference between the solid and the
dashed lines the dashed lines what's
happened we've narrowed our uncertainty
in the in the feedbacks and if you look
at the tail it's sort of
indistinguishable right so there's a
shift in the mode of the distribution um
but the tail really doesn't change very
much at all and that's really because
well
well there are a couple of reasons one
is this this inverse relationship the
other is that well you know we're
observing stuff today that is just
that's reflective of the of the climate
today right um so
to to expect to get a bunch of
information about very very high um very
very high uh temperature world from
observations that are
sort of based in today's climate is is a
bit bit too much to ask um so this tail
and climate sensitivity um you know some
of it is driven by the fact that you're
making this linear approximation um for
very high uh very high values of
feedback and those aren't physical
values up there so a climate sensitivity
of infinity which by the way these
distributions have
put weight on it's unphysical i mean
obviously the value of climate
sensitivity is bounded by the
temperature of the sun or you know the
temperature of venus or something like
that but it doesn't matter and the point
is that you don't you don't care about
climate potential sensitivity per se
what you care about is damages what you
care about is economics and livelihoods
and
this
is something you really care about even
up at 10 degrees here i mean we would be
in serious serious trouble if we find
the climate sensitivities in that tail
um so one point that i think hasn't been
made just yet is that although uh high
um
high climate sensitivity values are very
concerning
the temp the
temperature trajectory realizations on
those values are delayed and they're
delayed quadratically in the value of
the climate sensitivity so the higher
its climate sensitivity the longer it
takes you for the temperature to reach
that high that high value um and the the
sort of quadratic dominates the linear
right which means that at any given
point uh the distribution of temperature
is actually probably bounded right
um so this is something that's
illustrated in a nice model by bacon
rose the nice little analytical model of
the climate system and you can see that
as the the time scale gets really really
long
the time it takes to reach these high
values goes up i mean the important
point there is that you know we're going
actually going to a logarithmic scale
here
in time so for very very high values of
climate sensitivity this is a
probability distribution of the climate
sensitivity so for high values it's
taking a really long time to get there
that's really important knowledge for
economic models because uh because we
discount stuff that's far off right
so if these um
and the other reason of course is that
it just gives us a lot more time to
react a lot more time
to develop technologies to suck co2 out
of the atmosphere for example or solar
radiation management or whatever the
case is um
so the fact that these uh very very high
uh temperature trajectories are probably
deferred even if climate sensitivity is
high
is important for policy decision for
policy making um so
um
marty has has uh pointed out that
largely motivated by looking at the
distribution of climate sensitivity
although i think it's a mistake to see
his argument purely in terms of climate
sensitivity what he's really talking
about is damages and changes in
consumption growth rates um uh marty's
talked about the fact that
fat tail distributions sort of really
illustrate a form of non-robustness in
these integrated assessment models in a
sense that you can make very small
changes to the models the assumptions
the models make
about the distribution of consumption
growth or temperature change and get
them to sort of spit out the fact that
well
what you should be doing is paying your
entire income today to avoid these
fat-tailed risks tomorrow right
now
a simple way of seeing this argument is
that well to see that
welfare in these models is just it's
some integral over uncertain stuff right
and
in the standard parameterization of
these models you can basically boil this
down to some some integral over
temperature temperature to some power
some negative power
and by writing down
the
the assumptions in the models about how
consumption relates to damages and how
utility relates to consumption
you can actually solve for what this
parameter is what this uh sort of
scaling load the high temperature is for
for welfare and it looks something like
this it basically a component that comes
from the temperature distribution right
so that's the exponent of the
temperature distribution distributed at
high tail at high values how quickly the
distribution is decaying to zero there's
a component that comes from the damages
which tells you how how quickly damages
are escalating as temperatures go very
very high and the component that comes
from the utility function you assume in
the representation which is tells you
how much you value those damages right
how much do you care about the fact that
your consumption is going very very low
um
so i think this is actually quite a neat
representation of the things that we
care about in an economic model modeling
uh one is the science the other is the
economic
impacts and the third is the preferences
right
uh yeah yeah sorry this is this is for
the scientists in the order yeah it's
constant coefficient of this division
yeah
um and uh
so uh so the point is that uh
if this guy is is less than one
the welfare is is minus infinity right
so you this is something that you should
really care about in the economic models
and it turns out that it's actually
rather easy to find values of the
parameters uh where this is less than
one so in the standard models uh the
temperature exponent distribution is
probably two certainly the row baker
distribution has an exponent of two and
bill's model of damages the damages
decay or increased like a quadratic
function of temperature at higher
damages
and utility curvature let's treat that
as a parameter you can solve for the
value of utility curvature that makes
delta less than one with those parameter
values and it turns out to be about 1.5
and usually that the values of the
parameters that we use in these models
are about 2.
so you certainly can't rule out this
dismal theorem based on the on the
standard models
and
i think that like marty should really be
uh sort of applauded for pointing out
this uh importance of these are these
kinds of uncertainties and catastrophes
in these models and the point and the
fact that they are they may be
non-robust to sort of small changes um
in the distributions that we assume for
the parameters
um so it might however um
my reading of this result is is not that
it's a sort of paralysis of economic
modelling um
it's uh it's pointing out a
non-robustness so you have to seek the
origins of non-robustness and then ask
whether the criteria that are necessary
for that non-robustness to occur are
sort of irredeem irredeemable i mean
what can we do to remove that
non-robustness and it turns out that
well basically when it comes down to it
it sort of relies on the choice of
utility function which we which we've
used
for decades because it's what growth
theorists use and it gives you balanced
growth paths in uh analytic models but
for for the purposes of this kind of
numerical modeling there's absolutely no
reason to choose that utility function
at all um
moreover once you bound the utility
function below policy choices are
insensitive to the high tail right so
that's just a simple continuity result
if i imagine
um there is some
for any uh loss of a given size
there must be some probability of that
last small enough
that i sort of don't care about it right
so if i can reduce the probability of
that loss lower a small and smaller
small um i eventually just don't care
about that loss at all and policy
choices should reflect that kind of
continuity argument
um
so the point uh great thanks so the
point is that
there are actually lots of ways to to to
sort of
get rid of this this non-robustness in
the modeling but each of them requires
us to change the welfare framework that
we're using in these models and that's
one of the take-home messages i want to
send is that well welfare frameworks are
just as important as empirical inputs
for the policy recommendations of these
models right um
so uh
yeah so there
and
the choices that we make about welfare
frameworks should really be explicit so
i think um
that's the sort of take-home message of
the of the dismal theorem at least my
take-home message is that um
you know we need to we need to probe uh
the effects of these assumptions that
we're making in the models and see how
they affect the policy recommendations
they uh from the models and and present
that to policy to just policy makers
present a sensitivity over it
so um
i've talked a lot about sensitivity and
temperature but is climate sensitivity a
dominant uncertainty and are we not just
looking for our keys under the under the
lampshade right uh under the street lamp
because uh
you know climate sensitivity and it is
really one of the best quantified um
uncertainties in economic policy and
analysis of climate policy it's because
it's a scientific quantity it's not an
economic quantity it's something that we
can go out and measure as steve
illustrated um and it's it's really very
well quantified despite the fact that we
have lots of different distributions
over it
um
and you can ask well you know just look
at the look at the integrated assessment
models which parameters in these models
dominate the policy outcomes the policy
recommendations
um and here's a a result from a recent
study by assault an interesting
computational study by seltely who's
done a global sensitivity analysis of
bill's dice model
so instead of picking a subset of of the
parameters of the model and holding
everything else constant and then
varying one at a time what they've done
is
pick one parameter of the model
and find the conditional distribution of
some endogenous policy variable holding
that parameter constant and varying
every other parameter in the model right
and then vary the fixed value of that
fixed parameter and see how much
information you can you have of the
total distribution the unconditional
distribution
by
conditioning on that parameter so how
much information do you lose by just
fixing that parameter on average right
so it's a very very global measure of um
the sensitivity of these models and what
they find is that really it's the damage
function exponent that dominates right
so climate sensitivity is certainly
important but it's ranked fifth right
um there are technological parameters in
there that really matter um certainly
those two and there are also welfare
parameters that really really matter and
this is for the optimal carbon tax in
2015. so this is a policy relevant uh
parameter right
so
my my
feeling is like well
you know we
we economists sort of lag behind the
scientists in terms of quantifying the
quality of our models quantifying what
the models can and can't do and what the
risks are of using them um so i would
and it's and there's a good reason for
that because we're sort of engaged in
this huge out-of-sample exercise right
we're engaged in an extrapolation
exercise where we don't really have
law-like behavior that determines how
the economy is going to
grow and evolve and
behave in response to climate change but
one simple thing you can do is just try
and estimate the kinds of structural
uncertainties you would have in using
the kinds of laws that these integrated
assessment models
encode
by going back to the 19th century and
saying imagine that you used those kinds
of structural assumptions to predict the
20th century how well would we do on
average and here this is exactly what
i've done in this graph in ongoing work
so here the only thing that this
represents is uncertainty in something
called the total factor productivity
right so i'm assuming i know
everything else uh i'm prescient about
the for those the economists in the
model about the stocks of capital labor
um over the 20th century
and um
or the only thing i don't know is the
total factor productivity associated
with the productive production function
and i can ask well how well would i have
done if i went back to the 19th century
took 19th century data and made
predictions of 20th century economic
growth using these kinds of models
and this is this is a an example so the
black line is actual realized economic
growth and the gray lines are project
projections from
basically training the model on
different window lengths of data with
different starting points okay so that's
how we get the distribution over
growth projections here what you can see
is that actually the models do pretty
well for the first 50 years
and then in the last 50 years
there's a pretty serious bias right so
the realized value is is sort of out in
the tails of the distribution of
predicted values and that's really not
at all surprising so imagine what you're
trying to do you're trying to predict
all the kind of technological advances
that we realized in in post-war 20th
century the massive increases in
productivity associated with um
the enormous technological advances
we've had and you're doing that in the
19th century when carl benz had just
invented the motor car right
you cannot expect that data
to be predictive of um outcomes that are
policy relevant in the following century
let's be clear the last 50 years of this
century are what's policy relevant for
climate change right and growth rates
are what's policy relative for climate
change because they drive the discount
rate in these models very very strongly
so
so accounting for these kinds of you
know taking the models to data and
asking well what what are the risks
associated with the structural
relationships in these models seems like
a kind of
a weak but nonetheless necessary uh
exercise in trying to understand what
what are the sort of structural
uncertainties associated with the risks
associated with using a model for policy
it's not to say that the models are not
relevant for policy they are certainly
relevant for policy but we need to
understand the modeling risk and the
decision risk from using them as well
um
so my feeling is that you know the
climate scientists are actually a step
ahead on this task so here's an example
um where they've taken a whole bunch of
i think there are 25 models in the
sample
and plotted
some measure of model similarity so how
similar the models are in terms of their
replication of the of the 20th century
data against their ability to predict so
on the on the y-axis sorry on the z-axis
the the vertical axis here is their
ability to um there's basically a root
mean square error in their predictions
about uh 20 to 20 20th century
temperature or historical
temperature
and it seems like it's that axis it's
that vertical axis that we're missing in
climate in the economic side we don't
understand what the quality of the
models is we also don't understand how
they depend on one another and there's a
good reason for that they are
extrapolations they are um
best guesses for um
the future but it's also uh i mean it's
desirable to try and get it something
like this this uh vertical axis so what
do we mean by model quality what do we
mean by a model that's
structurally sound with respect to um
out of sample projections of the 21st
and 22nd centuries which is where
they're being used to inform policy
right
so um
my question is
can we come up with a figure like this
for integrated assessment models and if
so what would be the axis how would we
measure this thing and that's something
i really pose to the group
so what's my conclusion what can
scientists do
to inform economics and what can
economists do to inform policy well i
think
scientists
i mean this has already been discussed
this morning i mean we need to identify
what the
most relevant policy variables are
climate variables are for informing
policy and the variables that have the
highest potential for uncertainty or
reduction right
and um
so it's a sort of product of those two
things that really matter
and those are the things where research
effort should go into
um
the second thing is is really sort of
crossing this cultural divide and making
data uh and models and results really
accessible um and i guess that's one of
the great beauties of meetings like this
is that it encourages that kind of
cross-pollination um and keep telling us
what you do and don't know
and and
the other thing is go and read the
economics literature it's fascinating
and it's important it's really important
for taking the work that you do and
making it relevant to the policy world
because that's ultimately how we
transmit your information into into
government right
for economists um i think we need to do
much much much more
thorough sensitivity analysis of our
models and try to to estimate the sort
of risk of model the model risk by
calibrating the structural relationships
against historical data just to get an
idea of how wrong we might be by using
them
um avoid incredible certitude this is
charles manske's phrase this idea that
you know once you put a model out there
and it's sort of well the social cost of
carbon is 33.56
per ton and that's the answer you know
there are no central estimates in
economic modeling there are just
estimates right we don't have
centralized
moments over these
distributions
i think explore a much wider range of
structural assumptions and when we do
econometric work on impacts we need to
use the full suite of climate models to
force those impacts and it's very very
strongly um illustrated by a work by ted
mcgill and marshall burke and similarly
read the scientific literature it's
fascinating and it's important for
understanding how your models relate to
the underlying science that drives them
thanks very much